what about uh for you like uh because I
notice some producers once they get a
lot more
successful your time your bandwidth
becomes like less available for making
beats how much of your time do you
allocate to still actually like cooking
up on the laptop or in the studio like
bro it's early as hell I just left the
studio yeah you know what I'm saying at
like 600 this morning wow it's like a
job you know I don't treat it like a job
because I'm living my dream but I still
you know I'm still a hustler I'm still
out here and going to the studios and
going from place to place and you know
taking over the room and letting people
know that I'm here and I'm I'm available
all of this different stuff so I I I
would say all my time oh that's dope
yeah cuz some people I feel like they
get on they start popping and then they
got little mini producers is under him
man that was like but they tags on it
and it's like read the credits you know
mean there's 13 [__] on this
you know oh my God I that's the worst
bro like I mean and like some producers
that's what they do and they don't they
don't deny that that's what they do and
I get it you know as I get more into
this game and understand what it's about
you know I get it so it's not no shade
on nobody but for me it's like you know
I look up to like the Quincy Joneses of
the world and you know the the the Dr
Drees the people that were if you was
going to do that it was going to sound
incredible mhm and it was going to sound
like them and it was going to be their
sound right you know what I mean so you
can't do that and then you don't make a
sound like turbo has a sound turbo is a
super producer turbo is like you know
you can it's like a for real beat and
it's everybody knows his sound without
it even Happ to be a tag on it so if
you're not doing that then you just
cheating I guess who's on on your Mount
Rushmore of producers all time hip-hop
only hip-hop strictly hip-hop so take
Quincy out of my M you got to take
yourself off as well you can't be on
there yeah I I wouldn't even put myself
on there Mount Rushmore yeah four of
them four
people
um Timberlin for sure for
sure
um timbering for for
I would probably have to
say not even probably Z
toin for sure I love Z toin that's huge
fan of Z toin um Justice League oh I
love Justice going to have to put them
all on one head
yep and then you said four one
more
damn you killing
me only hip-hop only
hip-hop Dr Dre Dr Dre that's yeah
Justice League is so hard Justice League
is crazy BR like all the raw [__] I
always wanted to I always compare like
my circle in The Playmakers to like a
mixture of Justice League because it's
real music and it's real uh
compositions but like the the Trap sound
of like 808
right that's fire I always wanted to
like combine those yeah you know what I
mean and make it into like a thing
because Justice League had like
cinematic yeah like you be like huge
songs should sound like a [__] like a
movie yeah like a soundtrack like that's
I always say Ross always got the best
beat I still listen to it today bro like
like Ross's ear for Beats is like a
[__] up there man all time fact
that's another that's another person I
would love to work with like on some
whole project could just lock in [__]
like I love Ross